were you obviously today with the Pod
valuetainment you're very outspoken you
put your beliefs out there you don't
doesn't like you're not you don't really
seem like the guy that really worries
too much you know about like oh if I'm
gonna get this sponsorship whatever have
you always been like that even in your
other businesses have you always been
outside I claim to have been always that
so so here's the part I've always was
like that till
31 okay
and then I said okay you got to pump the
brakes and I'll give you a story
so I'm coming up I'm loud I'm rowdy I'm
getting up there I'm just whatever I
want is I'm just saying it all this
stuff and I'm I'm kind of getting away
with it for the most part uh I'm
respecting people sure I'm telling you
how I believe things I'm born in Iran
you know all this stuff and
So eventually I'm 31 years old we start
the insurance company I'm doing a radio
show in LA and Glenn Beck at the time
was a big name that was on Fox and he
had all this stuff but he was hated at
the time yeah so as much as Tucker
Carlson maybe hated Glenn Beck was hated
ten times more at the time absolutely
hate it so anyways one day we have a
meeting and Glenn ends up uh we do a
sponsorship with them and he does this
video to say things about us on this
radio show called krla and I'm deciding
to announce this and everybody's like
I'm about to make a big announcement
meet us at the Burbank Hilton or
Sheraton it's like 600 people at this
place I get up I'm like let me tell you
guys what just happened we got the
biggest guy sponsoring since 2010 to be
exact
we started company in 09 and I played a
30-second clip of Glenn Beck and I'm on
Fox News
and you see
60 percent of crowd is screaming
30 percent of the crowd is like neutral
10 of the crowd is walking out wow
so I'm like wait a minute I thought
everybody was going to be excited what
happened here this is the part about
being oblivious when you're a little bit
younger you're like just going and
you're wrong so my interest instead of
going to the guys that were excited or
the guys that were neutral I want to
talk to the guys that are walking out so
meeting ends I go right to them this
whole family from San Francisco They
said Patrick uh you know we love you we
followed you for six years but you must
not know a lot of politics because our
office is in San Francisco and the
moment they see this online we're not
going to be able to get any business
we're leaving you we love you but we're
leaving you and we're gonna have to shut
down the office and change it to another
company in that moment they made that
decision right there eh right there wow
so I'm in the car by myself and it's
easy to only listen to the people that
are saying wow that's sick that's
awesome because that's kind of how you
want to be soft and kind of make
yourself feel good but all I'm thinking
about is the other guys so I stepped out
and I said okay what kind of a company
you want to build Do you want to build a
company for everybody or do you want to
have a vision and a cause and a crusade
behind it I step back
and I said okay
we have to figure this part out we made
an adjustment we went a different
direction it was more neutral at the
time
and I said I'm going to come back to
this but I don't yet have a few money
and I need to have some real money yeah
because I need to have that money so I
can get louder later on because they're
going to bully you okay you know what
ends up happening we come back five
years later five years later
we put an event together and it's all
like non-stop capitalism capitalism
capitalism capitalism and we had an
event that President Bush came to Kobe
delayed Kobe Bryant was there Jordan
Peterson came there and then gradually
the guests I started bringing everybody
started saying oh my God passed through
this and around 2017 I kept telling
Mario Mario don't let me do any episodes
on politics don't let me talk politics I
would do a video and I'm like so today
we're going to talk about a Mario say
pad you're talking politics that's not
politics that's politics you told me to
tell you we can't do this episode
scratch it we gotta do something else
anyways long story short I held myself
for as long as possible
to see if this is a real mission that I
have or if it's just something that's
come in for a season and it's going to
leave you know sometimes you're like you
listen to a song and in two weeks later
you're over it you're like God listen to
it 200 times I don't care about the song
anymore I kept realizing I want to
listen to the song yeah and not only do
I want to listen to the song I want to
listen to all the songs by all the
artists and within this genre and then I
said I'm sorry this is a cause if you
don't like it too bad I'm rolling and
then at that point let her rip that yeah
I mean the reason and listen it's very
respectable and and the reason I say
that is because this podcast really was
born out of that out of not giving a
[__] to be honest during coveted during
covid and and again we're from Canada
very strict you know we won't go down
that road necessarily but I'm sure you
know about Canada how they handled that
in a big way yeah well they're still
going through it and and you know so
that was what this show was birthed out
of essentially and um you know we had to
make a decision because we also had the
agency you know 17 employees you know
not huge but people rely on us yeah and
we have of family friends like all those
things too that are affected when you go
out and you speak every year everything
business exactly family friends you're
ruining relationships so we had to make
that decision pretty early
um but we're well we're also in a
different position because we don't like
we didn't wait for the fu money
necessarily so we're and we're we're
stupid maybe we're still in this
constant battle yeah we're still in this
constant Battle of we want to put
episodes out on certain things that are
happening politically there's a
difference though and and so we're we're
always I'll tell you what's the
difference yeah and and that's kind of
where I'm going with it because we we've
we've missed out on sponsorship
opportunities we've missed out on
different you know having different
guests you know athletes NHL players
whatever NBA players that can't come on
our show because of things that we've
said and so we're always like [__]
should we have said that but then we
always find ourselves going back to but
no that's who we are that's our beliefs
and that's the way we're doing a role
right that choice that you even said
right are we going to be a brand with
with our own cause or are we going to
try and please everyone but I don't even
think you could do that anymore I don't
think you could please everyone anymore
I can give you my perspective and then
you guys can process it any way you want
so
when I did it
I didn't have anybody backing me up and
what I mean by backing me up is in the
insurance industry you would think
they're conservative the insurance
industry is filled with liberals wow
okay I'm on stage talking about
capitalism these guys are hating my
message because what I'm saying you
would think they're capitalists but
they're not I went to dinner one time in
Iowa and I'm talking to this guy back in
the days there was a company called ing
I don't know if you guys remember ing or
not yeah the Orange Line yeah yeah so
I'm sitting I'm talking and I'm talking
openly like hey you know America is the
greatest country this this that and
capitalism and freedom of choice and
second amendment we're having this
conversation we're at Cheesecake Factory
and often the guy's like well well well
yeah I don't know America is not as
clean as you think it is do you know
what America's done do you know what
American this do you know America that
do you know I'm like
what other places have you lived in
so next thing you know there is bumping
kids with a c-suite executive from that
company okay if you're watching you know
who you are so
and I'm not holding back because America
changed my life that's the one story
I've never compromised right
and then I said well you know this is
that well long story short we never did
business with ing that kind of fell out
it wasn't going to happen
so then I realized these guys all talk
to each other because the insurance
places I'll talk to each other and if
you don't have a lot of contracts to
sell insurance you're screwed you're out
okay so I took a position to kind of sit
back and watch everybody and then go
roll and play ball once I realized you
can't please everybody at the time I'm
in a small space
I'm like no this is what I stand for I'm
just learning how to communicate it
better there's a difference because
there's there's there's
20 different ways to tell somebody we're
breaking up
okay you can tell somebody you're a
piece of sh you know what I the hell
with you we're done yep that's a form of
saying breaking up what's another form
of saying we're breaking up honestly I
was talking to my mom yesterday and I
think you're too good for me
I don't think I'm at your level wow and
I can't be the man you want me to be and
I love you this is going to hurt me more
than it's going to hurt you because
there's hundreds of men that would love
to be with you there's probably not that
many women that would love to marry a
guy like me I have to let you go we're
breaking up yeah but one we're breaking
up with you hating me
the other one is like
what what's happening this is the best
breakup of my life yeah I literally I
love this guy you know we can't break up
no one's ever broke up with me like this
so I learned that I had to change the
way I delivered my message yes because
it's all it's as much in messaging and
delivery yeah as it is in anything else
foreign